So, we're back. What's the answer Micheal? How many rows do we have?
>> So if it was just one variable we're splitting on, then
it need to be true or false, so, that's two rows. If it
was two variables, then there's four combinations and three, would be eight,
combinations. So, generalizing the end, it ought to be 2 to the n.
>> That's exactly right, there are 2 to the
n different rows. And, that's what always happen when
we're dealing with n, you know, n attributes, n
boolean attributes. There's always 2 to the n possibility.
Okay, so I get just halfway there and I get to
your point about, combinatorial choices, among
the attributes. But ,that's only the
number of rows that we have. There's another question ,we need
to ask which is, exactly how big is the truth table itself?